.
>>> ALEX RODRIGUEZ RECEIVED ONE
OF THE LONGEST SUSPENSIONS IN
BASEBALL HISTORY FOR USING
PERFORMANCE ENHANCING DRUGS.
IN OUR CONVERSATION, HE TALKS
VERY CANDIDLY ABOUT HOW HE'S
WORKED TO COME BACK FROM THAT
AND ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE GAME
HE STILL LOVES.
YOU TALK ABOUT BASEBALL.
THE WORLD SERIES USED TO GET 40
TO 45 MILLION VIEWERS A YEAR.
THIS LAST YEAR, LAST FEW YEARS,
IT'S GOTTEN MORE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF 10 MILLION
VIEWERS FOR THE WORLD SERIES.
HOW MUCH TROUBLE IS BASEBALL IN
AND IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO
TO KIND OF RESTORE, MAYBE NOT 40
MILLION BUT TO RESTORE SOME OF
ITS POPULARITY?
>> CHRIS, I THINK LONG TERM, I'M
EXTREMELY BULLISH 200 YEARS FROM
NOW I THINK BASEBALL WILL BE
HERE AND HEALTHY AND GROWING.
SHORT TERM WE HAVE SOME
HEADWINDS AND I THINK THERE IS
TWO FRONTS TO THAT.
NUMBER ONE, THERE IS A TRUST AND
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE.
THE GAME IS SLOWING.
MORE SWING AND MISSES, LESS
ACTION.
YOU REMEMBER, I REMEMBER THE
DAYS WHERE A GAME WOULD BE TWO
HOURS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> A LOT OF ACTION.
AND THERE IS PITCHBILITY.
SOME OF THE GUYS THAT HIT THE
BALL THE FURTHEST IN MY CAREER
ARE SOME OF THE WORST HITTERS
I'VE SEEN AND SOME OF THE
PITCHERS THAT THROW THE HARDEST
ARE SOME OF THE WORST PITCHERS I
EVER SAW AND UNFORTUNATELY, OUR
ALIGNMENT TODAY IS PROMOTING
MORE ROCK THROWERS AND LESS
PITCHERS AND MUCH MORE GUYS LIKE
JOHN DALY CAN HIT THE BALL A
COUNTRY MILE BUT NOT GREAT
HITTERS --
>> SO IF YOU WERE SUDDENLY THE
COMMISSIONER OF BASEBALL AND I'M
TALKING SHORT TERM, NEXT FEW
YEARS TO TRY TO GOOSE IT UP TO
GET THE RATINGS FOR THE ALL-STAR
GAME OR FOR THE PLAYOFFS, THE
WORLD SERIES, WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
>> NUMBER ONE THING OPEN UP THE
FLOOD GATES.
I THINK PEOPLE LIKE TODAY,
DEMAND MORE ACCESS THAN BEFORE.
WE HAVE TO BE PROACTIVE.
MEANING, I WOULD PUT CAMERAS AND
GUYS, PLAYERS DRIVING TO THE
PARK.
I WANT TO SEE THEM AT HOME.
YOU CAN VET EVERYTHING.
THE CLUBHOUSES WIDE OPEN.
THE CLUBHOUSES, THE BATTING
CAGES, THE BULLPENS, INTERVIEW
PLAYERS, THERE WAS RECENTLY JUAN
SOTO WAS INTERVIEWED --
>> DURING THE ALL-STAR GAME.
>> IT WAS WONDERFUL.
>> HE WAS IN THE OUTFIELD AND
HE'D GET READY BUT IN BETWEEN
PITCHES HE'S TALKING TO THE
ANNOUNCERS.
>> AND DAVID COHEN ASKED A
QUESTION, WAIT, THERE IS A PLAY
IN CENTER FIELD BUT MY TEXTS
STARTED BLOWING UP.
I WAS GLUED TO THE TV.
I GOT TO KNOW HIM BETTER.
WHEN THE GAME WINS, THE TEAM
WINS, THE GAME WINS WHICH IS
MOST IMPORTANT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I KNOW
FOOTBALL DOES IS THEY OWN
THANKSGIVING.
THANKSGIVING, YOU'RE GOING TO
FIT THANKSGIVING DINNER IN
BETWEEN THE THREE NFL GAMES.
IS THERE ANYTHING BASEBALL COULD
DO?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT JULY 4th.
IT'S A WIDE OPEN DAY.
THERE IS NO FOOTBALL.
THERE IS NO BASKETBALL.
THERE IS NO SOCCER.
IT A NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
WE CELEBRATE THE GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
WHAT A WONDERFUL GAME TO HAVE
FOUR GAMES AT NOON, 3:00, 7:00
AND 10:00 AND SAY TODAY IS GOING
TO BE ABOUT BASEBALL AND EVERY
GAME WE'LL WIRE THESE GUYS AND
HAVE INTERVIEWS AND EVERYBODY IS
AT HOME WATCHING BASEBALL WHILE
THEY BARBECUE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR CAREER
IN BASEBALL.
OVER 22 SEASONS AND THESE
NUMBERS ARE ASTONISHING.
YOU HIT 696 HOME RUNS.
YOU WON THREE MOST VALUABLE
PLAYER AWARDS AND A 14-TIME ALL
STAR.
WHEN YOU BECAME ELIGIBLE FOR THE
HALL OF FAME, IT WAS ON 34.3% OF
THE BALLOTS AND WE NEED 75% TO
GET IN.
ALEX, HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN IT?
>> WELL, THAT'S ON ME.
YOU KNOW, I MADE MISTAKES.
I'VE TALKED ABOUT THEM.
I SERVED THE LONGEST SUSPENSION
IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL --
>> FOR TAKING PERFORMANCE
ENHANCING DRUGS.
>> YEAH.
AND IT WAS THE MOST EMBARRASSING
MOMENT OF MY CAREER AND IT WAS A
MISTAKE THAT I'VE NOW FORGIVEN
MYSELF BUT IT TOOK ME AWHILE AND
CHRIS, IT TOOK A LOT OF TURNING
THE LENS INWARD AND DOING A LOT
OF THERAPY AND UNDERSTANDING
SOME OF THE MISTAKES AND WHY I
WAS MAKING THEM AND HOW IT TIES
INTO MY CHILDHOOD BUT WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THOSE MISTAKES IS
THE BIGGEST GIFT AND CURSE OF MY
LIFE.
I LOOK AT THAT AND I THINK ABOUT
THAT EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT I DID
THAT TO MYSELF.
AND I HOPE THAT BECAUSE OF THAT
MISTAKE, THE LESSON IS I GET TO
BE A BETTER FATHER, A BETTER
PARTNER, A BETTER FRIEND, A
BETTER SON AND HOPEFULLY, OTHER
PLAYERS CAN LEARN FROM MY
MISTAKES.
>> TO THE DEGREE YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE SHARING, YOU SAY
THAT'S ON ME AND YOUR CHILDHOOD
AND THERAPY.
I MEAN, HELP US UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE SUCH A
GIFTED ATHLETE.
YOU WERE SUCH A SKILLED AND
ACCOMPLISHED ATHLETE.
YOU SAY WHY ON EARTH WOULD ALEX
RODRIGUEZ EVER FEEL HE HAD TO
CHEAT AND THAT'S MY QUESTION.
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
CHRIS.
I THINK ABOUT -- AND AT SOME
POINT IF I EVER WRITE A BOOK OR
DO A DOCUMENTARY, I'LL GET INTO
IT DEEPER AND DEEPER.
HERE IS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS,
SURROUND YOURSELF WITH THE BEST
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO KEEP
YOU ACCOUNTABLE IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THE OTHER PART IS, THERE IS NOT
AN EXCUSE.
MY FATHER LEAVING AT TEN, I HAD
A BIG VOID IN MY LIFE.
YOU KNOW, I ALSO HAD FROM AGE 15
WHEN THEY SAID I WOULD BE THE
BEST PLAYER IN THE COUNTRY AT 15
TO THE AGE OF 25 I HAD TWO
COACHES THAT WAS RICH HOFFMAN MY
HIGH SCHOOL COACH AND IN
SEATTLE.
I LAMENT.
I WISH I HAD AN EXTRA THREE
YEARS WITH BOTH OF THEM BECAUSE
BOTH OF THEM WERE MENTORS AND
TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF A FATHER
FIGURE AND SOMETIMES YOU NEED A
GOOD KICK IN THE ASS AND I GOT
IT AT 38 WHEN FINALLY MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT?
YOU'RE SUSPENDED FOR A YEAR.
THE HARDEST THING I'VE EVER HAD
TO DO IN MY LIFE IS FACE MY
DAUGHTERS NATASHA AND ELLA AND
TELL THEM THIS IS THE MISTAKE
DADDY MADE AND HERE ARE THE
LESSONS THAT I LEARNED AND I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT AS A
FATHER TO HAVE THAT MOMENT,
CHRIS, BECAUSE I GREW UP GETTING
KIND OF BULLED A LITTLE BIT AND
I DON'T WANT MY DAUGHTERS TO
EVER FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO BE
B.S. ME BECAUSE YOU GOT TO DEAL
WITH THE TRUTH, THE EARLIER, THE
BETTER.
>> SO, THIS MAY BE SOMETHING YOU
WANT TO SAY NOTHING ABOUT, YOU
CERTAINLY ATTRACT ATTENTION.
AND I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT ONE
SORT OF INQUIRING MINDS QUESTION
ABOUT JENNIFER LOPEZ, WHO YOU
WENT OUT WITH FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
YOU EVEN SET THE DATE TO GET
MARRIED AND BROKE UP LAST YEAR.
HONESTLY, DOES IT BOTHER YOU
THAT WITHIN DAYS AFTER YOU BROKE
UP THAT SHE WAS BACK TO SEEING
BEN AFFLECK AND THAT SHE ENDED
UP GETTING MARRIED TO HIM, NOT
YOU?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD SAY I'M
GLAD I'M NOT GOING TO EVER BE A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE BECAUSE
YOU WOULD HAMMER ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, WITH JENNIFER, LOOK, IT WAS
A GOOD EXPERIENCE AND I WISH HER
AND THE CHILDREN WHO ARE SMART
AND BEAUTIFUL AND WONDERFUL, I
WISH THEM THE VERY BEST.
>> THAT'S IT?
>> THAT'S IT.
>> OKAY.
I HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION NOT
ABOUT HER BECAUSE THERE IS A
LONG HISTORY OF YOU DATING
WOMEN.
YOU'RE YOUNG, YOU'RE SINGLE, WHY
NOT?
A LOT OF THEM FAMOUS WOMEN.
DO YOU THINK -- I WORKED A LOT
ON THIS QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE GOOD
HUSBAND MATERIAL OR DO YOU THINK
HONESTLY THAT YOU JUST LIKE THE
CHASE?
>> I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT MY
LIFE, CHRIS, I MENTIONED WHEN I
WAS 15 YEARS OLD AND I THINK
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" CALLED ME
THE TOP PLAYER IN THE COUNTRY
AND AT THAT TIME, I WAS ALEX
RODRIGUEZ.
AND THEN SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
WAY, AT 24 I GET $252 MILLION
CONTRACT AND PROBABLY LOST MY
WAY A BIT AND I BECAME A-ROD AND
AFTER THE SUSPENSION, I WORKED
MYSELF THROUGH A LOT OF THERAPY
AND WORK TO ALEX RODRIGUEZ --
>> WAIT, WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ALEX RODRIGUEZ AND
A-ROD?
>> WHEN YOU THINK THE SAME
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ALEX
RODRIGUEZ ME PRESUSPENSION AND
POST SUSPENSION.
I THINK PRESUSPENSION, IF YOU
ASK ME WHAT DOES WINNING LOOK
LIKE?
I WOULD HAVE SAID BIG CONTRACTS,
HOME RUNS, WORLD SERIES, YOU
KNOW, NICE CARS.
>> WOMEN?